[Music]
we're travelling through a mouse's brain
each color represents the branches of a
different nerve cell right now we're in
the space normally occupied by a blood
vessel but diving into the thick tangle
of nerve branches you can see how dense
and complicated the anatomy is this is a
reconstruction of a real piece of mouse
retina showing the precise shape and
location of 950 cells the researchers
who made it say mapping each neuron was
an almost insurmountable challenge first
this issue had to be sliced very thinly
an imaged by an electron microscope the
images were then analyzed by a computer
which assigned different colors to
different structures the computer was
very good at determining the volume of
each structure and identifying sign
APS's where one cell connects to another
but to join up the colored sections and
reconstruct the long branches of each
cell in three dimensions it needed help
so 300 students spent a total of thirty
thousand hours carefully tracing the
path of each neuron to tell the computer
how to join up to the colored blobs
together computer and students created
this but was all that effort worth it
this block with its hundreds of neurons
represents just naught point naught six
percent of the retina imagined scaling
up to a whole mouse brain or even a
whole human brain where there are over
80 billion neurons skeptics of this
approach known as connect omics say it's
too time-consuming and question how much
we actually learn about brain function
but in
enthusiasts argued that if you want to
really understand the brain
you'd better get mapping three studies
published this week in nature show that
mapping brain tissue in great detail is
giving us new insights into the visual
system the retina is the best studied
bit of brain yet this map surprised
scientists by revealing a new type of
cell one that's evaded other detection
methods because it's quite rare there it
is exbc a type of bipolar cell that
relays visual information from
photoreceptors to other cells in the
network it's a noticeably different
shape to other known bipolar cells the
other two studies looked at the retina
of a much smaller animal the fruit fly
they tackled a classic problem in
neuroscience how the brain detects
movement obviously really important to a
fly for 50 years we've had a vague idea
how this works the new studies finally
pin down the mechanism the first group
patiently mapped several hundred neurons
and by analysing their connections
identified motion detection circuits
each one wired to detect motion in a
particular direction
the second group studied the same area
of fly brain but instead of just mapping
they looked at cell activity
photoreceptor cells in the retina can't
detect motion so they focused on to
downstream processing neurons called t4
and t5 using fluorescent markers that
glow when a neuron is active
they showed that t4 and t5 neurons are
divided into four subpopulations
and like the previous study they showed
that each sub population responds to
motion in one of four cardinal
directions left right up or down
the precise wiring mapped by the first
group shows how information moves
through the network and so how the
direction is actually detected
together these three studies demonstrate
that extraordinarily detailed anatomy
combined with physiology is furthering
our understanding of the brain well a
tiny bit of fly or mouse brain will we
one day be able to map a holed human
brain to scale up the mapping process
needs to be fully automated and cheaper
and the data from a human brain could
fill millions of terabyte hard drives
computer pattern recognition isn't yet
good enough to trace long branching
neurons so full automation is a way off
for now researchers are making neuron
tracing into an online game so they can
crowdsource data and map larger areas
that's right
leading the next generation of neuro
scientists could be you
[Music]